now we were talking earlier about the
allegations about boris johnson and the
refurbishment of his flat so we can talk
a bit more about this and some of the
wider issues that it raises
with the former chair of the public
accounts committee day margaret hodge
thank you very much for being with us
um taxpayers money hasn't been spent on
the flats
boris johnson settled the bill why
should we why should we care
because when we become members of
parliament we all sign
up to a set of standards we promise to
be open
we promise to be honest and we promise
to be accountable
and in uh telling us about the downing
street flat
boris johnson has failed all those tests
he's been neither
open honest or accountable and
all the uh inquiries that are currently
taking place
on this issue they don't go to the heart
of the matter
so the electoral commission is looking
at the conservative party
his own adviser we know is toothless he
can't
initiate inquiries and we know that
boris johnson can ignore the findings
as he did with pretty patel so i think
it's really important
to have an inquiry into boris johnson's
own actions
and this is because it's part of a
pattern sophie it doesn't stand on its
own
it stands with the dodgy contracts it
stands with the
uh appointments that have been made it
stands with the
the greens hill scandal it stands with a
whole dyson
effort and all this has become a part of
a pattern
and we just have got to have confidence
in those who are leading us
particularly in these troubled times
what exactly do you think
the prime minister could be guilty of
here and is it a resigning matter
what sorry i missed that philosophy what
can he be guilty of
yeah what do you think he could be
guilty of hearing is it a resigning
matter
well we'll have to wait and see i mean
to be honest i think you know there's so
much going on at the moment it's
outrageous that we're having to spend
time on this we ought to be getting on
with the issues that are confronting
britain
like dealing with getting people back
into work or like dealing with the
social
care system which is so broken instead
we're having to focus on this
i don't know what boris johnson is
guilty of i do know
that he has got a form on this when
um i didn't enquiry into his actions
when he was
mayor of london uh at the garden bridge
and what came out of that
was a lack of honesty again uh
attendance
you know he gave contracts to friends
and he didn't go through the due process
there
and he wasted ratepayers money and that
instance 46 million
so he's gone that's the point isn't it
because you're talking about taxpayers
money there
which is quite different to what is
happening here
and actually if you're looking at
taxpayers money then you know boris
johnson isn't the only person to do up
the number 11 flat tony blair who you
saved under
spent 285 000 in his decade as prime
minister but was that all fine because
he's a labor
politician well hang on a minute
because it's i think this goes to the
heart of the matter
if you're dealing with these very
complex issues
you have to have confidence in the
people who are leading you
and if those people who are leading you
are not open
and not honest do not are not prepared
to be accountable
that brings into question whether or not
they are competent and appropriate for
leading this country
through these difficult times and it's
not a question of you know of boris john
if there's no such thing as a free lunch
sophie if somebody put
thousands of pounds into your bank
account
uh to pay for decorations if somebody
jets you over
to a caribbean holiday for free that
they will want something back there's a
favor they want back of it
and it's that issue it's not you know
that it's his personal money or that it
was party money
it's what are the favors that are wanted
back and if boris johnson
doesn't come clean you're left
suspicious
that actually it's impinging on his work
as prime minister
on the ppe contracts on huia points to
particular issues on how the greens hill
uh
scandal was dealt with on how he dyson
and his tax issues were issued were
there and is that the sort of britain we
want
do we want a britain you know britain we
i think we're in danger of losing what i
call our moral integrity
where uh you know all all those
standards in public life
which are so important in maintaining a
strong
open uh sophisticated and developed
democracy
they're all threatened here and we can't
have confidence and trust
in our prime minister that's what i want
to prove if there's nothing in it
come clean and then we can move on but
the moment he's refusing to do that
there's an allegation in the sunday
times today that the prime minister
asked a donor to pay for his
child care uh costs now number 10 has
said that the
promise had paid the cost they haven't
said whether or not he
paid the original bill or if he
reimbursed somebody else now when i
spoke to dominic rob he
dismissed this as gossip his title
tattle what's your view
well again the worry with this and
that's the other reason that this
issue is important is is does this stand
alone
or is it the tip of an iceberg and are
there other ways
in which the funding of his rather
lavish
lifestyle has been dependent on uh
individuals giving him cash and what do
they want in return of cash
there are two uh peers involved in this
both the
lord brown brownlow and zach goldsmith
both of whom were put into the house of
lords zach goldsmith has got a position
now
in government uh we've got to come clean
i do think that's one of the worries
is that is the downing street an
isolated instance or
are there are other instances like the
allegations around paying for the nanny
that could be there too and if that's
the case
if you're taking money in the secretive
private way how is it influencing how
you're approaching
the issues of state you can't go on like
that we can't have it and it's not just
me saying this i think this is above
party politics sophie
i think this really goes to the heart of
what we're about and there are a lot of
conservative commentators
from max hastings through who are as
concerned as i am
about the nature of the way in which we
are being governed today
this is this is a i think a really
dangerous point
in which our democracy could get very
undermined it's not just this it's
all sorts of things that happen you know
pushing aside parliament
uh sacking civil servants all these
uh you know not listening to the media
in the same way
not really caring about the rule of law
there are endless examples
where this administration led by boris
johnson
will not make maintain those standards
that are absolutely key for us being a
healthy democracy
we've got to attack key issues we
shouldn't be focusing on this
and we can't until we have confidence in
our prime minister
uh worth pointing out of course you know
we have approached lord brownlay for an
interview if zach goldsmith has got any
comment then we'd be very keen to bring
you that as well
um while i've got you i'm quite keen to
talk to you a little bit about the state
of the labour party
um because you know you're very
vehement about talking about the
failures of the current government but
at the same time
labour's struggled to find a lead in the
polls
for many many months now you've got the
local elections at coming up where
you're
looking like you could even be losing
seats like hartlepool that's
always been labor why is it that you're
just failing to cut through
um i don't accept that we're not cutting
through what you have to understand is
the general election in 2019
was the worst election result that labor
had uh experienced
since uh i can't remember 1930 i can't
remember the date but it's
decades and decades ago so we we've come
out of the worst position and
rebuilding trust with our voters
is something that will take time and i
think that's the first thing to say
if you look back at the tories in 1997
it took them time to rebuild it will
take us time coming out of that
appalling era
with jeremy corbyn as our leader it will
take us time to come back and i think
the second thing is
this is a very sort of surreal time
in politics we are all concentrating
on the uh on the pandemic and
uh i think that sort of creates you know
parties and politics is something we all
want to come together as a nation
which is why boris johnson's position
and his integrity
is so absolutely crucial and almost
above
politics but i think in that time people
are concentrated on different issues
and i think that's a second a second
issue and the third one is we have to
now
rebuild a sense of hope uh in the future
and it's going to take us a bit of time
to uh reposition ourselves but i'm
actually i think kirsten has done
totally brilliantly
i didn't voted for him in the in the
leadership election
but i've been very impressed by how he's
moved us forward
he's dealt with all the nasty elements
within the labour party
he's beginning to listen to people he's
starting to rebuild
trust and through a very difficult time
when he hasn't been able to sort of
be face to face with voters or do uh big
conference speeches
i think he's not doing badly i think
he's doing rather well
okay dave margaret hodge there thank you
for being on the program today